you've seen the logistic regression
model you're seeing the loss function
that measures how well you're doing on a
single training example you've also seen
the cost function that measures how well
your parameters W and B are doing on
your entire training set now let's talk
about how you can use the gradient
descent algorithm to train or to learn
the parameters W on your training set to
recap here is the familiar logistic
regression algorithm and we have on the
second line the cost function J which is
a function of your parameters W and B
and that's define as the average so it's
1 over m times of some of this loss
function and so the loss function
measures how well your algorithms
outputs y hat I on each of the training
examples stacks up compares to the
ground truth label Y I on each of the
training examples and the full formula
is expanded out on the right so the cost
function measures how well your
parameters W and B are doing on the
training set so in order to learn the
set of parameters W and V it seems
natural that we want to find W B that
make the cost function J of W comma be
as small as possible so here's an
illustration of gradient descent in this
diagram the horizontal axes represent
your space of parameters W and B in
practice W can be much higher
dimensional but for the purposes of
plotting let's illustrate W as a single
real number and B as a single real
number the cost function J of W B is
then some surface above these horizontal
axis WM B so the height of the surface
represents the value of J comma V at a
certain point and what we want to do is
we need to find a value of W and B that
corresponds to the minimum of the cost
function J it turns out that this took
function J is a convex function so it's
just a single big bowl you know so this
is a convex function and this as opposed
to functions that look like this which
are non convex and has lots of different
local Optima so the fact that our cost
function J of WB as defined here is
convex is one of the huge reasons why we
use this particular cost function J for
logistic regression so to find a good
value for the parameters what we'll do
is initialize W and B to some initial
value we've denoted by that little bit
dot and so the district regression
almost any initialization method works
usually you initialize the values to 0
random initialization also works but
people don't usually do that fill into
the regression but because this function
is convex no matter where you initialize
you should get to the same point or
roughly the same point and what gradient
descent does is it starts at that
initial point and then takes a step in
the steepest downhill direction so after
one step of gradient descent you might
end up there because it's trying to take
a step downhill in the direction of
steepest descent or as quickly down low
as possible
so that's one iteration of gradient
descent and after two iterations of your
in the sense you might step there three
iterations and so on against is now
hidden by the back of the plot until
eventually hopefully you converge to
this global optimum or get to something
close to the global optimum so this
picture illustrates the gradient descent
algorithm let's write out a bit more of
the details for the purpose of
illustration let's say that there's some
function J of W that you want to
minimize and maybe that function look
like this so make this easier to draw
I'm going to ignore B for now just to
make there's a one dimensional plot
instead of a higher dimensional plot so
gradient descent does this we're going
to repeatedly carry out the following
update and take the value of W and
update it going to use colon equals to
represent updating W so set W to W
liners
alpha times and this is a derivative D
of JW DW I will repeatedly do that until
the algorithm converges so a couple
points in the notation alpha here is the
learning rate and controls how big a
step we take on each iteration of
gradient descent we'll talk later about
some ways for choosing the learning rate
alpha and second this quantity here this
is a derivative this is basically the
updates or the change you want to name
to the parameters W when we start to
write code to implement gradient descent
we're going to use the convention that
the variable name in our code DW will be
used to represent this derivative term
so when you write code you write
something like W equals of colon equals
W minus alpha times DW so we use DW to
be the variable name to represent this
derivative term now let's just make sure
that this gradient descent update makes
sense let's say that W was over here so
you're at this point on the cost
function J of W remember that the
definition of a derivative is the slope
of a function at the point so the slope
of a function is really you know the
height divided by the width right
there's a little triangle here in this
tangent to jr. W at that point and so
here the derivative is positive value
gets updated at W minus a learning rate
times the derivative the derivative is
positive and so you end up subtracting
from W so you end up taking a step to
the left and so gradient descents would
you know make your algorithm slowly
decrease the parameter if you have
started off with this large value of W
as another example if W was over here
then at this point the slope here or DJ
BW will be negative and so the gradient
descent update would subtract alpha
times a negative number and so in up
slowly increasing W so you end up you're
making W for grant bigger which
excessive vibrations of green descent so
that hopefully whether you initialize on
the left or the right gradient descent
will move you toward this global minimum
here if you're not familiar with
derivatives of of calculus and what this
term D J of wdw means don't worry too
much about it we'll talk some more about
derivatives in the next video if you
have a deep knowledge of calculus you
might be able to have a deeper
intuitions about how neural networks
work but even if you're not that
familiar with calculus in the next few
videos we'll give you enough intuitions
about derivatives and about calculus
that you'll be able to effectively use
neural networks but the overall
intuition for now is that this term
represents the slope of the function and
we want to know the slope of the
function at the current setting of the
parameters so that we can take these
steps of steepest descent so that we
know what direction to step in in order
to go downhill on the cost function J so
we wrote our gradient descent for J of W
if only W was your parameter in logistic
regression your cost function is a
function of both W and B so in that case
the inner loop our gradient descent that
is this thing here the thing you have to
repeat becomes as follows you end up
updating W as W minus the learning rate
times the derivative of J of W be
respect to W and you update B as B minus
the learning rate times the derivative
of the cost function respect to B so
these two equations at the bottom are
the actual update you implement as an
aside I just wanna mention one
notational convention in calculus that
is a bit confusing to some people I
don't think is super important that you
understand calculus but in case you see
this I want to make sure that you don't
think too much of this which is that in
calculus this term here we actually
write as follows with that funny
squiggle symbol so
this symbol this is actually just a
locate deep in a fancy font in a
stylized font but when you see this
expression all this means is this is J
of W comma B or really the slope of the
function J of W comma B how much that
function slopes in the W direction and
the rule of the notation in calculus
which I think is in total article but
the rule in the notation for calculus
which I think just makes things much
more complicated than you need to be is
that if J is a function of two or more
variables then instead of using
lowercase D you use this funny symbol
this is called a partial derivative
symbol but don't worry about this and if
J is a function of only one variable
then you use lowercase D so the only
difference but you want to use this
funny partial derivative symbol or
lowercase D as we did on top is whether
J is a function of two or more variables
in which case you use this symbol the
partial derivative symbol or V J is only
a function of one variable then you use
lowercase P this is one of those funny
rules of notation and calculus that I
think just make things more complicated
than they need to be but if you see this
partial derivative symbol now all it
means is you're measuring the slope of
the function with respect to one of the
variables and similarly to adhere to the
you know formally correct mathematical
notation calculus because here J has two
inputs not just one this thing at the
bottom should be written with this
partial derivative simple but it really
means the same thing as you know almost
the same thing as lowercase D finally
when you implement this in code we're
going to use the convention that this
quantity really the amount by which you
update W will denote as the variable DW
in your code and this quantity right the
amount by which you want to update B
will denote by the variable DB in your
code all right so that's how you can
implement
straight into send now if you haven't
seen calculus refuge's I know that that
might seem like a lot more derivatives
in calculus than you might be
comfortable with so far but if you're
feeling that way don't worry about it in
the next video we'll give you better
intuition about derivatives and even
without a deep mathematical
understanding of calculus sort of just
an intuitive understanding of calculus
you will be able to make new networks
work effectively so that let's go on to
the next video where we talk a little
bit more about derivatives